the Prime Minister has just been giving
an interview Boris Johnson has been
talking about plans to deal with the
cost of living crisis amongst other
subjects it's just coming to us here at
Sky News let's take a listen
so uh it's very important to remember
the the 1200 pounds going to eight
million vulnerable households uh in
October you're going to get four 400
pounds going to virtually everybody
that's 29 million households will get
400 pounds in November every uh
pensioner is going to get 300 pounds to
help with the cost of energy plus
everybody who's entitled to disability
benefit is going to get 150 pounds now
all that all that all that all that is
on top of what we're doing uh with
increasing the living wage increasing
support through Universal Credit but you
promised at the weekend
the extra support and on top of all
those billions of pounds which is
fantastic but we've known about that for
weeks now
um are you aware of for instance what
Liz truss's economic plan is Rishi
students Camp saying that she hasn't got
one we were hoping to hear tonight's an
interview which you pulled out from do
you know what her economic plan might be
yeah look at so so again let me give you
the the the things there's a huge amount
coming already come 650 pounds already
come a lot more to come what the
government is also going to do and
whichever of the two candidates gets in
uh next week what the government is also
going to do is provide a further package
of support for of helping people with
the cost of of energy what we've got to
do is get through the tough months head
I'm not going to you know shrink from
this it is going to be it is going to be
tough in uh the months to come it's
going to be tough through uh to next
year and that's because of Putin's war
in Ukraine being absolutely no doubt the
gas prices gas gas gas gas gas is being
driven by what Putin did in Ukraine but
we're going to get through it this year
you're going to be a statistic well
we're taking 26 more of our own gas uh
from the North Sea than we did last year
but we're much less dependent on Putin's
supplies June uh this year took zero uh
fuel from Russia for the first time in
decades and at the same time time what
we're doing and I just want to give
people a sense of of Hope and
perspective because the crucial thing in
addition to the cash that we're putting
in and don't forget we can put the cash
in because we're in a strong economic
position basically we have very low
unemployment we have the Reserves uh
because we came out of code let's just
quickly move our promises I know you've
not got very much time to complete one
point very quickly very very important
because people do care about this they
want to say they want to know that we're
going to have the long-term British
energy security strategy and we are uh
we're putting in more nuclear and you're
going to be hearing more about that
later this week and we're putting in
absolutely shed loads of wind power as
well three more questions yes let me ask
about Pakistan obviously we've seen
these uh devastating uh floods there
um will the UK be sending a package of
LA to Pakistan yes of course and uh I
can tell you that our sympathies are
very much with the people of Pakistan
and we've seen the devastation uh that
it's it's absolutely heart-rending that
Pakistan is traditionally one of the
biggest recipients of UK overseas aid we
will of course make sure that we send a
a a fitting package commensurate with
the vital relationship that there is
between the UK and Pakistan and People's
Natural uh sympathies with those have
been affected by the floods